comme bien d'autres pistes cyclables à
montréal celle de la rue villery
s'arrête abruptement
elle sera prolongée de 5 km vers l'est
une protection supplémentaire bien
accueilli j'aime pas trop circuler à
vélo justement cencig récent et pistes
cyclables famille un peu de la pression
avec les voitures il ya les gens qui
donnent l'espace ya des gens qui donnent
pas l'espace la ville de montréal va
lancer une quarantaine de projets cette
année pour améliorer ses pistes
cyclables ou en aménager de nouvelles
les tronçons visite totalisent près de
36 km un investissement de 17 millions
de dollars des projets qui visent à
consolider riboud a consolidé à
sécuriser leur réseau cyclable existant
toujours pour un la pratique du vélo
plus attirante
un premier tronçon du réseau express
vélo fera notamment son apparition sur
le boulevard henri bourassa dans
l'arrondissement saint laurent
et le déploiement du rêve se poursuivra
aussi au centre ville dans laxe viger
saint-antoine saint jacques vélo québec
salue la volonté de la ville mais estime
qu'elle [ __ ] trop lentement pour
atteindre son objectif de doubler la
taille du réseau cyclable il faut aller
plus vite au rythme actuel s'apprendre
40,1 pour achever le plan vélo on est
très déçu de cette annonce là tu vélo
fantôme s'inquiète pour la sécurité des
cyclistes alors que sept d'entre eux
sont morts lors d'accidents l'an dernier
à montréal oui il faut sécuriser les
intersections mais c'est qu'ils manquent
des pistes siffler unidirectionnelle
séparer de la route d'eiffage russes ont
beau bien eu ce genre de leur unique
petit ce club tout petit j'ai
l'impression que tu t'en vas turquie
peut être entraîneur donne
d'administration qui allait avec
beaucoup de plus de kilomètres mais
c'était beaucoup de peinture sur la
chaussée nous on fait vraiment des
projets de qualité par ailleurs la vie
leur a à l'oeil les automobilistes qui
se stationnent dans les pistes cyclables
des agents patrouilleront sur le réseau
express vélo de la rue saint denis dans
le cadre d'un projet pilote mon circuit
et même à vélo sur la piste pour pouvoir
venir intervenir faire remarquer aux
besoins a donné une contravention
la ville souhaite étendre cette
initiative à l'ensemble des pistes
cyclables ici olivier bâche un réseau
canada montréal